bei uns im studio ist weiterhin findet
peter auf unserer meinung chef weiter
die zahlen hinter den zeilen noch einmal
genau anschauen ganz entscheidend findet
dabei ist natürlich auch die impf
situation dass boostern jetzt das große
stichwort wir fragen uns natürlich wie
viele menschen sind geimpft für wie
viele menschen kommt der booster
überhaupt infrage damit mehrere grafiken
vorbereitet die wir jetzt gemeinsam auch
einmal anschauen wollen als erstes mal
den blick auf die situation jetzt gerade
die impf situation hier in deutschland
diese grafik wenn man sie jetzt einmal
genauer anschauen wie viele menschen
sind vollständig geimpft das aufgeteilt
nach altersgruppen
vollständig die impfung sehe ich hier
der über 60 jährigen sind bereits 85 5
prozent sind 20,6 millionen menschen das
ist die entscheidende zahl aber das ist
die wohl gruppe und die es jetzt geht
die altenheime die wir schützen müssen
das bedeutet aber auch schon wir hier
auf diese rot eingefärbte zahl 3,5
millionen menschen dort sind eben noch
nicht vollständig geimpft wir sehen
natürlich bei denen der jungen 12 bis 17
jahre auch da gibt es noch richtig
aufzuholen auch dass wir eben gerade im
gespräch mit den steuern noch mal gehört
da jetzt halte sich fast schon helft der
hälfte aus also und dann schauen wir in
die mitte 18 bis 59 jahre dort sind 73,6
prozent geimpft und ja 26 4 prozent den
fehlt noch der peak sie sind bisher noch
ungeimpft das also philipp hof derzeit
die situation hier in deutschland wir
sehen also zwei extreme einmal die alten
die zwar schon gut geimpft sind aber
immerhin noch eine große zahl auch die
einem deutlichen risiko im moment
derzeit aus stehen und wir sehen auch
bei den jungen also bei denen ab 12 die
stiko empfiehlt die impfung auch ab 12
auch da tut sich noch nicht so richtig
was ja ich glaube dass relevante sind
die ist die risikogruppe das sind die
senioren die noch nicht geimpft sind und
da tut jeder ungeimpfte ältere mensch
einfach deutlich mehr weh als als
dutzende junger menschen die sich nicht
haben impfen lassen und da frage ich
mich ob die bundesregierung und die
landesregierung gerade die richtige
strategie fahren die führen ja
flächendeckend zum teil 2 g 1 sowie
bayern das jetzt macht so die sachsen
das jetzt gemacht hat auch mit dem ziel
auch wenn sie es nicht aussprechen aber
auch mit dem ziel natürlich dass
menschen sich impfen lassen aber die
frage ist doch wer lässt sich impfen
wegen zweig die menschen die in
restaurants gehen wollen die menschen
die ins fitnessstudio gehen wollen da
sind vor allem jüngere menschen die
frage ist erreicht man denn die älteren
dadurch also ist das für ein 70 75 80
jährigen tatsächlich so schlimm wenn er
jetzt mal im herbst und winter für
einige wochen oder einige monate nicht
ins restaurant kann ich sage es ist für
ihn deutlich weniger schlimm dem druck
auf ihm ist überhaupt nicht so hoch wie
man meint und er lässt sich vielleicht
auch nicht impfen und da muss man ja
eigentlich hinkommen und die frage ist
ja auch die booster impfung man weiß bei
älteren menschen nimmt der impfschutz
rapide ab jetzt heißt es ja wir müssen
so schnell wie möglich boostern bewusst
dann aber unfassbar langsam bewusst dann
langsamer als der italiener langsamer
als die österreicher langsamer als
hybrid langsamer als die franzosen und
wir sperren habe die impfzentren
überhaupt nicht auf also die hausärzte
sagen wir sind total überfordert sieht
sollen wir die leute auch noch
anschreiben wie sollen wir das denn
machen anstatt dass wir einfach
flächendeckend die impfzentren aufmachen
und schauen dass wir auch wirklich tempo
aufnehmen machen wir das einfach nicht
also für jeden ganz ganz viel ruhiger
als müssen wir verschärfen und mein gott
ist die intensivstation fühlen sich
jetzt ist alles schlimm ja dann mustert
die leute doch warum macht ihr denn
nicht alles um diese menschen zu ostern
weil es teuer ist fahrzeugen aber das
ist doch das allerbeste investment was
man machen kann kennst du schon jemanden
der geburtstag ist erkennt im moment
fast noch niemanden außer wirklich ja
freunde von großeltern usw aber ich
kenne ganz viele die nach wie vor so
viele fragen haben wo kriege ich das
ding her da nachschauen oder dürfen sich
also so viele fragen sind da offenbar
noch die die regierung nicht ausreichend
aktuell beantworten kann danke an bild
meinung chef philippe piatti er uns ein
bisschen erklärt hat was tatsächlich
hinter diesen aktuell steigenden corona
zahlen alles steckt